today I want to take a little bit of a
closer look at a scene from Alfred
Hitchcock's masterpiece vertigo it's an
early scene in the movie when the
retired detective Scotty played by Jimmy
Stewart visits an old college friend
Gavin Elster how did you get in the
shipbuilding business yeah specifically
I want to look at how Hitchcock blocks
this five-minute and 20-second scene and
how his staging of the characters adds
to the story I married into it now I
should say that there are two ways to
look at the scene
from the perspective of a first-time
viewer who has to take the information
it presents at face value or from the
perspective of someone who's already
seen the film and knows the true
intentions and outcomes of what's
revealed here I'm going to take a look
at this from the second perspective
which means that there's going to be
spoilers so just a heads up so if you've
seen vertigo you know that in the scene
Gavin Elster is spinning an elaborate
lie in order to create an alibi so that
he can get away with murdering his wife
in his plan Scottie is the alibi Gavin
tell Scottie that his wife is possessed
by an old spirit ask Scottie to spy on
her then switches his wife out for an
actress who plays that part cleverly
exploiting Scotty's desire and his
vertigo Gavin and the actress murder his
wife and leaves Scottie traumatized
believing that the wife committed
suicide
the scene in question the one in Gavin's
office at his shipbuilding business
comes only eleven minutes into the film
and comprises Gavin's attempt to lure
Scotty into his deception how did you
get in the shipbuilding business yeah I
married it the scene starts with Gavin
seated at his desk and Scotty standing
behind a chair in the center of the room
in the beginning it's Scotty who's
dominant he's asking questions
moving around Gavin's desk leisurely
inspecting various objects like a
retired detective might by acting and
sitting rather coyly Gavin lures Scotty
into his space and his confidence under
the illusion of sincerity I always liked
it here how long have you been back
almost a year Scotty continues his
inspection moving to the other side of
the room to see an old picture of San
Francisco his back is turned
just as Gavin makes a key confession yes
I should like to lived here then colour
excitement's ah freedom it's that
freedom he desires freedom from his wife
that's launching this cruel plan of
course the audience can't know it then
but Hitchcock's foreshadowing is there
and it's in the staging too while he
sits Gavin is in front of a window that
shows a ship behind being put together
piece by piece not unlike the story he's
about to spin for Scotty would you like
a drink now no I don't think so little
early in the day right Scotty moves
toward Gavin again and sits in the
centre chair asking him the purpose of
their meeting and here the power changes
hands as Scotty
sits in the hot seat Gavin stands and
begins to tell his story he moves around
the desk and up a couple of stairs so
that he's towering over Scotty even
higher I want you to follow my wife no
it's not that we're very happy man well
and
I'm afraid Sam ha may come to hope
someone did when Gavin makes his big
reveal that his wife is being
supernaturally possessed Hitchcock
brings him in closer to Scottie so that
the ankle is even more extreme far now
from being coy Gavin's blocking becomes
aggressive and the next thing that
happens is perhaps the most interesting
moment in the scene Gavin and Scottie
remain fixed in their positions but the
camera dollies backwards to bring them
both into frame now the camera moves all
over the scene but this movement is the
only that really calls attention to
itself this is a reminder that for
Hitchcock blocking involves the position
of the camera too there are three
elements in this scene not just to
Scottie expresses his disbelief at the
situation in Gavin sitting again softer
and tone acts like he understands sorry
I wasted your time thanks for coming in
Scotty Scotty gets up and moves toward
the door to leave Gavin lets this happen
because he knows that to really rope
Scotty and he has to make it seem like
it's his own choice Scotty apologizes
and Gavin moves into his space again and
before Scotty can say anything Gavin
starts in on the details of his lie how
his wife seems to fade in and out of her
personality how she wanders around to
odd places and Gavin himself is
wandering in the second room which is
raised a few steps like a stage and
Scotty moves to the chair on the
opposite side like an audience member
watching his performance
I followed her one day watched her
coming out of the apartment someone I
didn't know he even walked a different
way got into her car and drove out to
Golden Gate Park five miles set by the
lake staring across the water the
pillars are stand on the far shore
you know portals of the past it sat
there a long time without moving I had
to leave get back to the office when I
got home that evening I asked what she
done all day
she said she driven out to Golden Gate
Park and sat by the lake that's all well
speedometer on her car sure that she
drove in 94 miles of course what Gavin
is doing here isn't recounting details
but planting them in Scotty's head
details that will match with his
actresses actions in the following
scenes this layer of stage performance
is a stroke of genius on Hitchcock's
part because on one level vertigo is
about the power of film and the power of
narrative how a really good narrative
can manipulate us whether it's for the
purposes of entertainment or something
more sinister the narrative laid out for
Scottie in this scene will drive the
whole rest of the story
it'll drive Scotty's actions in the
first part of the film and eventually
it'll drive his own obsessive narrative
creation in the second part I've got a
nose Scottie where she goes and what she
does before I get involved with doctors
well have you talked to the doctors at
all about them yes but carefully when
Gavin steps back down into the lower
room the monologue ends and the
conversation resumes Scottie gets up
from the chair to protest Gavin's
request for help but he's moving toward
him
Gavin mirrors his movement and
approaches Scottie entering his space
again this time with his final bargain a
simple request we're going to an opening
of the Opera tonight we're dining at
Ernie's first you can see her then the
scene ends with Gavin literally leaning
into Scottie and Scottie finally
relenting the trap has been set
Hitchcock even frames it so that the two
are overlapping I've always loved this
scene in vertigo in college I used to
diagram it out in my notebooks trying to
figure out where he put the camera on
what lens is he used but it's the
blocking for these five continuous
minutes that are the real mark of
Hitchcock's mastery of the form the
scene is small and often overlooked but
it holds up the rest of the film how
many other directors could choreograph
this conversation in such a way that it
works like a dance where one man is
leading and performing and the other is
a spectator and a patsy without knowing
that yet both Gavin Elster and this
scene have Hitchcock written all
over them in other words I don't think
it's a coincidence that the man himself
isn't too far away
everybody thanks for watching I really
did diagram the scene in my college
notebooks and I encourage you guys to
pick out a favorite scene of yours with
complicated blocking and do the same I
think it can be really illuminating
thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video the nerdwriter is my
full-time job so pledges and
sponsorships on this channel help me
keep my nose to the grindstone just to
make more videos which is what I love to
do and Squarespace is actually really
great really professional-looking sleek
intuitive websites you don't have to
know coding to make one and you can get
a free domain if you sign up for a year
you can start that free trial at
squarespace.com and if you use the offer
code nerdwriter and get 10% off your
first purchase Squarespace you should
thanks guys I'll see you next Wednesday